what i love is when you see the before
and after pick and it's so
obviously not the same person yeah i
love it
i love those it's just like someone so
morbidly obese that
they think that because they now have a
six-pack he can't recognize that it's
just not the same the lighting's totally
off
like the belly button is totally
different like that there's no hair
like one okay so one thing one thing i i
always find funny is like why
always in the before the before pick do
does like the cameraman just say
look as depressed as you can yeah i just
just just like
it's like you're conscious like you're
smiling why are you smiling this is the
before pic you know yeah yeah i mean in
the uk but they're just depressed in
both but i mean
it's just it's like subconscious right
you see someone smiling you you
your [ __ ] dumb monkey brains thing oh
good yeah yeah that's a that's a good
thing happened yeah good thing it could
happen thing here
i don't know i just i i get really sad
when i know that like clearly someone's
buying this stuff
and like the detox teas that just make
you [ __ ] yourself
it's just like [ __ ] yourself of
course you're gonna lose weight because
you're [ __ ] out all the stool that
you have in there like
you know of course you're gonna lose
weight but it's just sad that people
like feel desperate enough and
they can't just like believe the fact
that it's like just eat less
yeah sometimes it's not that simple
though i know but that's the core of it
you see less just don't get cyberbully
just turn off the pc
but like that it sucks because just
don't get hungry
that's what it is like the fundamental
of it is just like eat less
[ __ ] obviously there are exceptions and
then you know someone in the comments
being like i have ex
yeah okay good but like a fundamental
visit don't buy this [ __ ] you know
it's
yeah but that's the thing it's like the
people who are buying into that kind of
stuff usually
or all yeah that's all it is like all
they need is just like a change of diet
or just something so
[ __ ] easy and yeah they're just like
just don't be fast listen
listen i can vouch for the chicken and
broccoli diet
it works it works wonders the chicken
and broccoli diet is no joke i
it worked wonders for me a simple
payment of 6.99
trade offer trade offer you get chicken
and broccoli you lose weight
it's as simple as that literally i get
79.99 you get chicken and broccoli
i need it can a chicken and broccoli
company team up with me i will show it
dude
is there a chicken and broccoli there
actually is on ubereats around our area
there is
there is literally a chicken and
broccoli chain that just delivers
chicken and broccoli
this is how it works guys it's not fun
but weight loss isn't fun
it's like it doesn't need to be i i feel
like i mean
it's it's sad that you know some
sometimes in like self-improvement
a big factor in whether it's going to
succeed or not is if you're [ __ ]
enjoying yourself doing it yeah
it's it's unfortunate right but like
like like
for me like for example going to the gym
versus going to do like a sport or going
to do like a
like another active activity right
that's like doing that activity is way
more fun than spending
even like i could do three hours or
something of a sport
versus 30 minutes on the treadmill and i
choose like a three hour sport any time
but that's
but that's the thing like that's why i
think nintendo is like gigabrain when
they release ring fit
because that is literally the answer to
like you can lose weight and have fun
but no no okay but this is the this is
like
i say that having never played it
but i plan to get it i plan to get it
this has been sold out for a while
the big problem that we have been like
believing for so long with weight loss
and this is like mainly
like i i know this is like [ __ ] kids
free literally it's like okay okay
disclaimer none of us have weight loss
things yeah don't take our advice
but it's like you know the big companies
like
coke mcdonald's and all them they're
like yeah dude you can drink as much
coconut you can eat as much mcdonald's
as you want all you gotta do is just
exercise
it's not it's not the food it's exercise
and it's like exercise doesn't really do
that much for weight loss no it's like
but what weight loss what i find
personally what exercise does do is the
day when i exercise
i am like vigilant about what i'm eating
i'm like yeah no
no carbs here like no sugar for me for
me the day when i exercise for some
reason i just you take care of yourself
yeah i know
i i actually crave healthy foods right i
don't know what it is about
yeah but like if i get if i go to the
gym for an hour that day that day
afterwards i'm just like man i'm kind of
just craving a chicken breast
yeah i [ __ ] this pizza [ __ ] the curry or
whatever
but like when i'm just like being a
couch potato just like sitting at you
you know you're just like yeah yeah i
feel like [ __ ] so i kind of just feel
like i'm gonna eat [ __ ]
exercise yeah i feel like going to the
gym or like just exercising in any way
you can is like it's not so much
the act of losing it it's just like the
motivation yeah
it's good for obviously it helps you
know general fitness yeah healthy and
it's good i'm not saying it's bad but
like
i feel like we have definitely been like
believe me it's not the cream
yeah we've also just been like told when
we were growing up right that if you
well if you eat 10 doughnuts just burn
off the calories and then boom no damage
that's that's not how it is 10 doughnuts
10 kilometers on the treadmill it's like
that's not
at the end of the day it's it's you know
you could you could go in the gym and
distract yourself with it but it comes
to that moment when you're sitting on
the couch or you're wondering what to
eat and you've got to just
have the willpower to be like oh chicken
broccoli
fine fine yeah exactly you know it sucks
because it's like not funny that is all
diet i mean i i feel like whenever
whenever you do any kind of
self-improvement activity it's not the
days where you feel good
that's going to define if you basically
succeed it's the days where you feel
bad and you're able to push yourself
through and i say this
being like i've had plenty of times when
i have failed because i felt bad and i
just didn't
just not there's not not even the
motivation to push myself through i just
didn't have the self-discipline because
i feel like
self-discipline is way more important
than motivation because there are going
to be some days
where you are just not motivated then
it's those days where you can push
through
yeah and i know plenty of people who
have i'm not one of them unfortunately
it's like as well i i found that like
when i was it's easy to like
eat really healthy for like two weeks
i'm not easy but it's doable
right yes but then it's like all right
well if you just go right back to doing
what you were doing it's like well
nothing's changed well that's where the
bounce back happens well i mean that's
why i like i
i was just like what can i cut out that
it's like i can i can keep out like
forever so i don't drink like
soft drinks ever yeah like the last like
that [ __ ] yeah the last like
since juice probably the beginning of
quarantine i've just made a conscious
effort to not drink any like fizzy
drinks or anything like that it's just
interesting [ __ ] like that tea and water
it's tea water coffee is all i'm [ __ ]
drinking
yeah i mean i i i was lucky enough that
i just never have craved
like soda or anything in my life i've
just always grown up on drinking water
and
it's kind of made me realize that man
the habits you the habits you had as a
kid
really just like it's it's so much yeah
they stick with me it's so much easier
to learn a habit once
than to unlearn it and to learn
something else and i feel like
so much of my life like if i could like
if i had a time machine if i could
[ __ ] easter kind of myself back
into like a younger body there's so many
things i would do to be like okay you
learn this you learn this habit you
learn that habit so you don't have to
[ __ ] unlearn it
yeah and like and like have like a
[ __ ] year of your life being like
well i have this shitty habit that i
just had as a kid and
it's kind of [ __ ] me over and i wanna
i wanna try and do something else but
god damn this pizza feels so [ __ ]
good right now
yeah it's like it's not even like i
don't even eat that [ __ ] anymore i most
certainly do
yeah i kind of like trying to balance it
out how much i do eat and uh yeah
yeah it's not like an everyday thing
right yeah i hate talking about the [ __ ]
online because everyone's just a [ __ ]
expert about it like in the comments no
doubt they'll be like 10 people would be
like
i'm a nutritionist expert i'm here to
tell you that you're totally wrong yeah
um because because everyone's got their
own opinion because most people have
gone through it
experience of seeing what's worked for
them and yeah but that's the thing it's
what's worked for them
right and that doesn't mean it works as
long as you do it helpfully you know
you're not starving yourself like you
see some people like yeah i lost 10
kilograms in a week it's like that
sounds like a terrible idea
what did you do that sounds like it must
have been some painful shits yeah
yeah i mean i i feel like it's i think
one
important thing is that just because
something worked for someone doesn't
mean it
doesn't necessarily mean it's gonna have
something else and it's it's really like
uh
what i found is it's really a trial and
er what was it like
an hour trial and trial and error
yeah you either eat this or you [ __ ]
die you either
you try or try dying how about just try
starving yourself
you either lose weight or you die i used
to be like [ __ ] paranoid about like
what's in this thing but i just started
thinking like if i just eat a reasonable
amount of things
yeah and exercise i think i'll be all
right
yeah and that kind of worked
i was like carbs i eat a lot of carbs
but like i just eat them within reason
like
but my meals are never too big like i
feel like i eat a fair amount of food
like i
i feel like the one when i stopped
giving a [ __ ] about calories and stuff
like that and just thinking like
is this portion stupid yeah yeah is this
a whole large
domino's pizza do i should i eat this
probably not so probably not gonna do it
like